all righty hope everyone's doing well
don't mind me I'm just get myself some
water
all right ah Oh fix that you're gonna
end up with a with a loop there for a
minute I mean can I get that a little
less crooked slightly I'll take it
I've watermelon water with it with me
sounds lovely Meg yes foamy t-shirt this
is old as heck like this has gotta be
this year's gonna be a decade old at
this point at a guess writers Club of
the Daleks
[Laughter]
hufflepuff from Scotland actually made
it whoo glad to have you back Amanda so
um yeah as the title implies I figured
that this time around we would talk
about writing because I have written a
novel that I have made the commitment to
myself at this point mostly to published
next year now this is most likely gonna
end up being self-published because I've
tried shopping the novel around and
having gotten any bites as yet and
that's several years I've been doing
that Council do you live in the UK no I
live in Northeast Vermont in New England
USA missed the last two cuz I slept haha
nothing wrong with catching up on sleep
but anyway so well it's not impossible
doing the parts that I'm working on with
the book right now I will probably
continue to shop it around to a few more
publishers see if any of them bite but
I'm not expecting them to so my plan is
to anticipate self-publishing but this
as a very long-term project this is a
book that I started writing in college
so about 15 years ago 15 16 years ago
thereabouts no no crap
17 17 years ago because it was my second
year of college might have even been 18
depending on when in the year I started
that part I don't remember so at this
point has become one of those things
where like I just need to get it off my
back and done cuz like it's I've been
working on it in various degrees for so
so so freaking long ah can we know what
the book is about yes what it is is a
fantasy story I am going right now with
fantasy adventure cuz it's not an epic
fantasy it's not on that biggest scale
but it is in a fantastical world that
has a mix of steampunk style technology
but also a lot of natural fairy or the
referred to as the Fae in the book magic
and humans and Fae don't don't get along
and the primary the the main character
as well as a few others are what are
called elementals being that they are
humans who exhibit very basic elemental
powers so the main character Faris is a
fire elemental what that means is there
are fiery energies that basically build
up within his bodies that he has to
expel and try not to hurt anyone doing
it because having this kind of magic
elemental magic is not a gift it's not
cool the amount of control and the
elemental has over it is incredibly
limited and as a result they are very
feared among other humans but being
human just with these abilities they're
not they don't exactly have a place in
the world of the face
either so you have these people torn
between their two different the two
different sort of worlds that exist not
having a place where they belong and
following as I said a fire elemental
mainly as he basically tries to just get
free of the elements that pursue him and
there's a lot more to it than that as
far as you know background and and you
know the character's motivation world
building and all that but I'm not gonna
get into that too much cuz actually I
should I should confess to this as well
I have actually started an author diary
on this which is it's something that
that I really resisted ever doing but I
am doing it with this it is a patreon
exclusive series the reason I decided to
do that is because I really want to
commit to the author diary and see it
through the entire process of what I'm
doing and also going back over the stuff
I've already done but I don't think that
the view count and the subscriber
interest on that I think some people
would be very interested but I don't
think the numbers would be there and I
think if I released that as a regular
feature on the channel that it would
actually drag the channel down as far as
the algorithm goes so as a result of
that it's kind of not in my interest to
put it up on the general YouTube and I
figure the people who probably are the
most interested in hearing it most
likely are the folks supporting me over
on patreon so that's where that's going
up first video on that one up today
basically just as a statement of purpose
and and that is I'm getting my plug in
there so you got you got to insert the
plug smoothly it's very important so I I
that is available to all tiers of
support on patreon even the one dollar a
month support tier gets you access to
the author diary which is going to be
right now the plan is a bi-weekly upload
for that
ah so let me just jump back to this as a
non-binary person I'm getting good vibes
Oh Bob welcome I'm listening to one of
the Otzi crow Shaw story MOG world is
bloody hilarious I bought I'm trying to
remember which of his I bought on audio
and I haven't gotten to you I think I
bought will save the galaxy for food I
haven't started it yet because I'm
working on other you know writing
reading projects that I'm trying to get
through oh so okay so here's your
reminder and I'm pretty sure the person
who said this knew that drink question
tonight is my thoughts on the d23 Star
Wars footage which I don't really have
any I don't really know what to make of
it if I thought much of it I actually
would have done a video on it but like
it's so brief and so out of context I'm
not enough of a speculation person to
did just start throwing theories out
that's just not where my head's at I
could try to do it but it'd be pretty
disingenuous of me and that would just
be clique hunting I'm not gonna say I
never come up with theories but it's so
rare that if I'm not feeling it
naturally I'm not gonna force it and
yeah uh-huh
force it huh Star Wars and and before
I'm ashamed
ah let's see here still not seeing the
Star Wars Star Wars footage well I mean
it's basically got one very intended to
stir up interest sort of bit of imagery
in it the footage told us nothing it was
pure fanservice I'm not sure if that's
fan service because fan service has to
be something that fans want I don't know
of what that footage implied which I
seriously doubt is exactly what it looks
like because just look at the track
record of the Star Wars marketing for
the main saga but so I seriously doubt
it is what it looks like and I'm not
sure I'd call it fanservice cuz I'm not
sure that's what fans want but it is
very much a
get people talking because I think they
know that the speculation cycle keeps
Star Wars in the conversation a lot I'm
very cynical about the footage yeah I
mean I don't blame you
waves hand you you will give your
opinion I mean that's kind of all of God
is what I said when writing fantasy do
you in embrace tropes or do you prefer
to subvert them there are some tropes
that I deliberately went out of my way
to avoid at all costs I'm not avoiding
all tropes and the ones that I come
across aren't necessarily ones that I'm
doing on purpose or trying to subvert
but the ones that I went out of my way
like I I had a set of rules they do not
do under any circumstances rule which
were actually basically linked because
they have a similar vibe to them but
they were no chosen one actually were so
there were three but they're all kind of
connected no chosen one no prophecy no
darkness gathering strength none of that
those are my three rules for this book
was to not tread in any of that because
as much as I can enjoy you know big
epics you know world-shaking stories
that's at the end of the day not my
favorite kind of storytelling I'm really
partial to what I think of as big
stories and sorry small stories in a big
world
so my quintessential example for that is
always Blade Runner because the world is
massive visually you get so much the
history in the sense of this place but
the immediate story being told and the
characters involved are not important
not in the grand scheme of things and
that's the same reason that my favorite
Star Wars movie is a new hope and my
favorite Lord of the Rings movie is
Fellowship of the Ring it's the one it's
the ones before the stakes became save
this entire world that's and that's just
kind of where my where my head goes and
so that's that was very much the the
sort of scale that I wanted to work at
for this story
I wanted it to be a story that maybe
would cross over with significant events
in this world but none of these people
none of these characters in this story
are ever gonna be written about in the
history books they are not the movers
and shakers of the world they're just
trying to get by I prefer to subvert
tropes but not on their own we have to
gain something by subverting the trope
yeah I mean subverting it for its own
sake that can that can be just as
dangerous as just giving into it
what changes most about your book since
you started writing it apart from how
much you've written um I mean what
changed the most was sort of the scale
of the narrative so that the story was
always fairly small but as originally
written I I had a lot more point of
points-of-view
then I ultimately ended up with so
trying to think of the best way to put
it so there are still multiple points of
view it's not like first-person
narrative but but we jump um you know
from I think I think ultimately I ended
up with three three arguably four points
of view but one is very clearly the
primary point of view my first finished
draft and the first few revisions had
probably six or seven points of view it
was much more ensemble piece but what I
realized as I was revising was I kind of
lost the the main narrative thrust and I
the character who I had always kind of
positive my head is being the main
character didn't feel like that anymore
because it felt much more about a story
of an event than a story about this
character so I had to dial back the
number of perspectives and narrow the
focus much more clearly on who is my
main character and part of that is what
happens with just falling in love with
your own creations because part of the
reason I ended up with so many
perspectives was I really liked a lot of
these characters and I
he wanted to spend more time with some
of them and the only way that I could do
that was to lend them their own
perspective because narrowing it down to
the main character primarily meant I
lost whole scenes that just the
perspectives I restricted it to meant I
was I wouldn't get that scene there's no
way I could have it but I ultimately
realize the narrative didn't need it I
just wanted it so those are the kind of
things that happen over time I find
cutting down work oh hang on I lost it
let me back up here I find cutting down
work to its minimum is an interesting
experience and love minimalism in my own
work yeah I getting it what genre is the
book sci-fi I assume no it's actually
fantasy there are sci-fi elements
because there is sort of steampunk esque
technology so that that's kind of there
but yet narrowing down has been I mean
that's basically what I've been doing
for the past five years or so with the
book is just focusing focusing focusing
although this latest revision I did end
up adding two chapters primarily because
there was there was a character who for
what ends up happening to land properly
I realized we needed more time with this
character just raw time um and I had so
I had to figure out what to do then I
realized if I just rearranged a few
things it gave me uh gave me some extra
time without anything to add a
perspective but just gave me more time
in this in the scenarios I'd already
created and I'm working on that right
now when do you think you'll get it
published um next year is all I'm
committing to right now I'm I'm going
through another revision right now I'm
also huh
this is me getting ambitious I've
started working with an illustrator so I
don't know how many illustrations I'll
ultimately end up commissioning for this
it's definitely not gonna be one a
chapter I can't afford one a chapter
it's too many but it is there are going
to be
illustrations at select key points for
either key beats or establishing things
you know like the first time the main
character sort of gets a look at what
ends up being the primary location of
most of the book I that is an image I've
actually already commissioned so we get
the first look of this location because
that's gonna be important so I've got
that going on that's part of my things
right now and what will probably happen
is after I finished the revision pass
that I'm doing I'm gonna start looking
for beta readers to to get a pass on
that and then if I'm very lucky enough
I've gotten paired with a publisher
start working with them on a final edit
and if I haven't find a way to scrape
together the money to hire my own editor
which is what I had to do with with my
last book with skirting gender which is
in fiction this will be my first you
know work of a fiction
you know prose fiction for God's sake
hold on guys this damn thing sorry give
me a second I've got this thing that's
popping up and blocking my view there we
go um do you have any advice for writers
with less of a platform for getting
their work out there and thanks for
answering in general I really don't
because the problem is I'm not actually
great at self marketing what to whatever
degree I have a platform at all it's by
accident I don't know how I got like
honest to god um there are some
youtubers out there who have a lot of
really good advice and some of whom I've
taken but there's one Oh God ham let me
see if I can get her name correctly from
Ghana uh Jenna Moretti Jenna Muricy last
name is spelled mor e CI she does a lot
of videos I'm talking about things
like publishing through you know the the
advantages of publishing through Amazon
versus publishing through Ingram I've
done both you know working on getting an
audiobook put together general things
that she's very good she has a lot of
really good advice and she's definitely
much she's very good at the marketing
end of things she has built herself a
platform they in a way that I definitely
haven't how would you feel if a fourth
Star Wars trilogy has ever announced
okay
I'm counting that as the Star Wars
related questions so everybody drink
they kind of have announced a fourth one
because supposedly Rian Johnson's still
working on his own separate trilogy that
isn't part of the primary saga what
Lucasfilm has said is that the main Star
Wars saga the Skywalker saga the
numbered series ends with episode nine
and I expect them to hold to that have
you ever read The Wanted comic series I
have not I saw the movie liked it well
enough but I mean it's also Mark Millar
and my I'm not a huge fan of Mark Millar
if I'm being completely honest
would you ever write your own Doctor Who
novel I mean if they commissioned me if
they paid me heck yeah
for fun no I take it you're heard
there's going to be a Breaking Bad movie
coming to Netflix soon I did and they
had the first trailer and interestingly
it looks like it's going to be a direct
continuation focusing on Jesse Pinkman
which I mean okay
I'm curious and having it on Netflix
makes it an easier call cuz I have
Netflix so for my intent for all intents
purposes for me it's practically free
hang on I'm gonna jump back over to
discord real quick and just see what
questions I was given there because as a
reminder the discord is a patreon
exclusive perk and if you are on the
discord I actually have a channel for
the live stream were
where folks even if they miss the stream
can ask questions and I promise that I
will address them here the ones that
answer them asked in the discord I of
course try to answer all the questions
that I can but at this point like the
thing stalls by quick and sometimes I
ramble so I don't yeah I don't get to
everybody let's see how close to the
idea that you initially had in your head
is what you have written down now in the
case of the book um the first thing that
I scribbled out in relation to this is
literally about half of chapter 1 as it
exists right now it's actually crazy how
little the core idea changed like the
idea and the presentation got refined
but from initial kernel to general
outline to writing it down very little
changed broadly speaking in terms of the
way the narrative flow tonight pretty
much ended up with what I thought I
would well that's a good thing wrong I
don't know we'll see if anybody likes it
when I actually put it out there so who
knows what are some of the positive and
negatives you've discovered about
self-publishing is this something you'd
recommend uh whether or not I would ever
recommend self-publishing I think has to
do with two things one how much are you
prepared to market yourself and I say
that as someone who does not do that
well and I know I don't do that well and
part of the reason I don't do that well
as I don't enjoy it I don't like selling
myself I like just doing what I do and
hoping people find it that's the first
thing because if you enjoy that and or
are good in it at it ideally both then
self-publishing makes a fair amount of
sense because you know you'll you'll be
good at the thing that you need to do in
order to you get the thing out there the
other thing is do you prefer
and we're frozen yogurt generally ice
cream checkout skulduggery pleasant okay
anyway so as I was saying the thing was
self-publishing the reason I went the
route of self-publishing both with
skirting gender and probably will end up
doing with this book is I've already
been shopping around for publishers for
a few years and haven't been getting any
bites and at this point I've basically
accepted that I'm not going to find a
publisher for these works and so at this
point it becomes a matter of I need to
be I need to be able to draw a line
under the this project and be done so
that I can move on to other things cuz
otherwise it's always gonna be occupying
part of my brain space so broadly
speaking if I if I could have gotten a
publisher either for my last book or for
this one I would I would absolutely get
with the publisher for a number of
reasons one most publishers if they are
of any note because there are a lot of
shady publishers out there like
quote-unquote publishers like you do
have to be very careful cuz if word gets
out that you're trying to shop around a
book you're gonna get solicitations from
from shady people but assuming you pair
yourself with an actual publisher
generally they're gonna cover the
editing which is a serious expense so
there's that and then any decent
publisher has a marketing on you'll be
expected to do as much marketing as you
possibly can but if they're gonna go to
the expense of getting an editor on it
and publishing it they're gonna want it
to sell so therefore they're gonna
actually put at least some marketing
muscle behind it that most of us don't
have so for me self-publishing is the
because I don't think this is gonna get
out there otherwise option it's
basically the nuclear option it's not
something that I actively recommend
based off my personal experience both in
terms of going through the process which
hasn't been awful but again I know
there's important elements that I'm not
great at and then just also the
fact that I'm pretty sure that a
publisher could have sold more copies of
my last book in my play then I have
managed to so you know if I could I have
someone to help with those things I
would I would absolutely love that but I
don't so I I do what I can with what I
have and I move forward I tried to write
a Doctor Who story the notion of writing
a Doctor Who story again which I
probably wouldn't even attempt unless
I'd somebody paid me
I'm very intimidating the very idea of
trying to write Doctor Who's is
intimidating I watch Torchwood children
of Earth after your review I like the
storytelling but it was really
uncomfortable to watch yep yep is it
possible to love something and hate it
all at once yes it is absolutely it is
the black mirror episode white Christmas
I love it and I hate it it's absolutely
possible to love and hate something at
the same time quick rate all five
Jurassic park's what unlike a scale or
just relative to each other because I
could probably rank them better than I
can rate them I don't think in terms of
rating systems oh cool you have a play
how different did you find it for me for
some reasons and I find it easier to
have long works in play for me well the
play okay I gotta be careful how you
talk about the play because the play is
not for the under-18 crowd um but the
play actually was very very smooth
writing experience for me because I've
acted on stage I mean community theater
I've never been a professional actor but
I've acted on stage alone so I'm very
used to two scripts in the flow of
scripts and thinking about as an actor
how do I want this to read so writing
the play was actually for me very easy
and it also left out a lot of the stuff
that takes up a lot of time when you
write a book because when you're write a
play
you are generally stage directing you
only write down what is super important
you you let the director and the actors
figure out how it's gonna be
presented otherwise so you don't have to
go into a ton of detail describing every
action that a character takes only key
ones whereas when you write in prose
when you write a novel or a short story
you need to very clearly and thoroughly
explain what is going on I have try I
have tried to watch Ralph breaks the
internet earlier oh I'm sorry
you ever gonna visit Doctor Who's origin
country what the UK I already have I've
been there so I found is how I found
Doctor Who I was in London on my
honeymoon and I was browsing channels
I'm gonna hop back to the discord real
quick
any tips on improving dialogue writing
um yeah just say it out loud and if you
have a friend who you're not too
embarrassed to have have the have the
two of you speak it to each other and
just hear how it sounds said cuz
generally if you have stilted dialogue
if you actually found a way to hear it
you'd realize oh that doesn't sound
right I said that as someone who really
enjoys writing dialogue that's usually
actually the first thing that I write is
I'll sketch out dialogue and then fill
in the rest later
I decided to do what you did rewatched
new era doctor week by week on Wednesday
tomorrow I'll be on DMT child
Oh Ben will enjoy that it's a good time
nonfiction related but I've always been
wondering this for a while what do you
prefer the racnoss from runaway bride or
giant spider different my rack kids in
the UK I suppose I'll take the racnoss
that's slightly more inventive how do
you feel about fan fiction I feel like
that's a way people get into writing I
mean that's how it works for me to be
honest um I mean fan fictions fine I
mean I I'm definitely not anyone who I'm
not someone who judges fan fiction
alright or judges anyone who writes that
like what I encourage people to write
and whatever in
spires you write that if what inspires
you most is an existing creation then
write that because the more you write
the more it becomes a habit and it's
something you do regularly you'll find
the more ideas that you have which is
the biggest trap that so many aspiring
authors fall into they just sit on this
one idea forever and just like keep
focusing on that and like maybe the only
outliner they won't even really write it
but the more you write and the more
variety of things right you write it's
like anything you put in your 10,000
hours at something you will become good
at it and I mean that's become true of
me with video editing I can turn these
things around very quickly and I can
usually ramble and not have to do a lot
of edits because I've done it a lot of
sound a lot of time into it not with a
goal of getting better on it just
happens it I mean yo
so whatever keeps you writing and if
that's fanfiction awesome
write fanfiction understand that you're
probably never gonna get to you know
publish it not if not without a series
for reworking but whatever inspires you
to write do that absolutely hold on I
said I was gonna jump back to the
discord before so now I'm actually gonna
do that like I said it would um would
you be opening to help write a script
for a sci-fi comedy TV pilot I'm working
on uh I would if you paid me other than
that like I've got too many things going
on to be lending free help on other
people's projects like I don't mean to
sound super mercenary but that's just
that's just kind of its kind of the
reality do you have any tips on how to
write compelling characters um what I
would say is there there's a thing you
should do but then you need to be
careful not to do something as a result
of that first thing you should know the
background of the history of your
characters and you should know the
reasons why they behave the way they do
you they they should never be
ding for no reason other than its what
moves the plot along you need to
understand your his your characters
history backstory motivations ways of
thinking but having said that you need
to resist the temptation to dump all
that information into the narrative
which is very tempting to do because if
you sink a lot of work into a
character's backstory in history and you
know like their entire life from
childhood up to whenever the story
starts you're kind of gonna want to show
that off you're going to want to put
that in but don't if it's not irrelevant
to the immediate story don't put it in
but have that knowledge so that you
understand the full dynamic of the
character you're writing but just avoid
the temptation to and to shove all that
context into the story if there isn't a
reason to put it there see um let's see
said here somebody asked a good question
but I didn't see it hang on let me back
up see if I can catch it how do you
tackle the subject of symbolism and
being subtle versus only thinking you're
being subtle example alec anakin and the
prequels being immaculate virgin birth
um I mean from my part I I don't do
symbolism not on purpose I my own I tend
to favor the JRR tolkien approach which
is to aim for applicability but not
allegory the difference being allegory
is something where you directly put
something in be it a character and event
what-have-you that has a one-to-one
correlation in the real world you wrote
this thing and it really represents this
I don't do that and that's where you
tend to get symbolism it tends to come
in hand in hand with allegory I favor
applicability which is you write
something that could be interpreted as
this or maybe this but does not
automatically oh it must be
I think applicability is way more
interesting and way more accessible than
allegory allegory is where you tend to
get really pretentious it's not
impossible to make allegory work but in
my mind it's much harder to make that
work it's one of those things where like
it's hard to thread that needle any
advice on writing short film scripts I'm
doing is trying to be efficient only
include things that move the plot
forward I mean that's the main thing if
you're writing anything short whether it
is a film script or a short story or
what-have-you
succinct this is going to be your key
and this is honestly why a lot of shorts
especially short works of fiction short
stories almost always tend to have
twists or reveals at the end because you
don't have the time to get into super
depth of the characters so a good way to
try and make your story stick in
somebody's mind is to have a twist not
them necessarily saying you should
inject one if there isn't one already in
your story but I'm just saying that's
why they tend to show up in shorts
almost all the damn time but other than
like whittling it down to being as
sharpest and also realize being
efficient is not the same as being fast
you can take moments and have a slower
pace and still have an efficiently told
story efficient efficient just means no
fat nothing there that doesn't need to
be there it does not mean that you're
going breakneck speed although if you
want to do that you know that's a choice
do you draft characters based on people
you know personally or does your lawyers
say not to answer this um not on purpose
but it does happen they're looking back
there are a number of characters in the
book who I know exactly who that is
based on at least in terms of the
initial spark of the character I don't
try and keep them consistent with their
real-life counterparts because then I'm
kneecapping my narrative but yes I will
never name names as to who any of those
are but and it's not every character
either but there's a fair number of the
characters although oddly not
the main character but a fair number of
the characters in in that book have
direct inspirations from people who have
known what are your favorite Jean I'm
Jean remind tends to be fantasy in
sci-fi
I mean I do like fantasy in sci-fi
I tend to gravitate slightly more
towards sci-fi because sci-fi is more
likely to do the thing that I talked
about way at the start of the the feed
which is small stories in a big world
because sci-fi can deal with you know
the the the smallness of humanity how
small we are in the Universal scheme
so whereas fantasy really tends to lean
into epic stories more often than not
but you know that's not always what I
favor but I do like fantasy quite a bit
hang on let me catch back up here Gail
Simone is a great comics writer oh yeah
she is I love Gail Simone I was like um
Warren Ellis more often than not Chris
Claremont great yes finally taking care
of my my federal student aid
congratulations Connor best of luck to
you hmm
who is your favorite comic book writer
or writers okay so in try and think is
anyone I mean Neil Gaiman when he writes
comics Alan Moore is always interesting
I don't always like what he does but
he's always interesting even his more
recent stuff like Promethea was
fascinating it's weird but it's
fascinating I'm fairly new to comics I'm
looking for some new great stuff to read
there's so much to choose from I mean if
you want to stick within superheroes
Gail Simone is a very safe bet she's
very very good what audience is your
novel aimed at also I've seen your video
on killing characters in the LGBTQ
spectrum so is one of your main
characters LGBTQ so I have a well
alright there are two characters in the
book who are somewhere on the lgbtq+
part of that hole
spectrum only one of them is explicitly
noted as being such one of them isn't
because I legitimately could not think
of a way to make it clear because that
element for that character just is not
part of their story in this particular
narrative at all and I just could not
figure out how to make it clear it's
implied if you pay attention but I
expect most people won't catch it
funnily enough I've actually written 75%
of not necessarily a follow-up to to
this book but something set in the same
world and that has a number of X and has
a higher percentage of lgbtq+
characters than this book does though
there are some in here oh and in terms
of what audience is the Nominating that
and that's part of why I like I'm not
great at marketing because it probably
could where it could work for a young
adult audience it's certainly accessible
to young adult audience I I would say
even possibly middle school range but
it's not necessarily specifically
targeted at that age range it's lacking
a lot of the elements that you would
often put in a why a novel there's no
love triangle there's no sort of
equivalent of a high school dynamic you
know that there isn't a lot of the
things that are normally injected in
something specifically aimed at yaa so I
tend to think of the book as young adult
and up for a target audience but again
if I was better at marketing I could
answer that better and um I'm just I'm
not have you ever read rat Queens
I love rat Queens one of the episodes of
the podcast I do with Liz tough like a
girl part of the fire water network go
subscribe we covered the first volume of
that yeah that that books great I love
it if you were to write an episode of
Black Mirror what you're
what would your central idea or a
technology be it I don't know because I
haven't thought of one already and I'm
not I'm not gonna sit here and have you
watch me go huh for 10-15 minutes while
I try and think of something so I don't
know if to top your head who would you
want to see play your setting in
tabletop RPG form well I mean biased
answer I'm gonna say the cast of
improvised weapons cuz that's my
favorite RPG podcast so people should
have seen that coming
you're why sounds like my why a no love
triangle more coming of age no romance
yeah I mean yeah pretty much
and mine's not even necessarily coming
of age it's more trying to get free so
that he so that he has the ability to
come of age cuz he's just had he's got a
lot of things potentially restricting
his life what is the piece of writing
that you are most proud of this is off
the discord funnily enough the piece of
writing and most proud of is a short
story that I've also shopped around and
as net and has not gotten published
I don't expect ever will but I am super
proud I did it's the short story it's my
take on the last human being alive story
I'm really proud of that short story
like I I'll go back and reread it some
times to see if I want to revise it
again and I don't end up tweaking more
than a couple words and I always end up
going like oh no I'm really happy with
that dang so I keep falling into this
this is also off the discord so I keep
falling into this trap of all my
characters being males in their early
teens because that's what I relate to
most any tips on how to stop doing that
well the the easy way to start stopping
ooh goodness excuse me the water came
back up on me because that sentence made
sense so the easiest way to start
stopping doing that is just write the
characters as best as you understand
them then go back and start tinkering
with who they are
and altering things like their age their
gender their race but don't just do it
and then change nothing do it and then
figure out how would that alter the way
that they behaved so I I've always said
I've said this with representation and
with everything else it's much easier to
change something that exists then try
and make something perfect that is that
is it tangible yet so I think you'll
have a much better luck trying to alter
characters that you actually have
something down on the page for then
trying to formulate something that's
outside your experience before you even
write it down so write what you know and
then go in and add the nuance and the
diversity and things like that
now as you ideally get more comfortable
with that if you do that for long enough
you'll get better at starting to think
of these characters at the very
inception of the story as being
something other than you know a direct
equivalent to your own experience but as
a place to start it's okay to make the
changes retro actively so long as you go
through the through line of realizing
okay if I take this male character and
make them a woman instead how would that
change the way they behaved how would
that change the story and then make
those changes because otherwise its
sheer tokenism let's see would you want
your book to get adapted into a film I
mean that'd be nice
I wouldn't expect it to because for how
much it would cost to make it's not an
epic enough story and that's another
thing especially with epic fantasy
fantasies are expensive and in the minds
of Studios big money means you tell a
big story and then it's very
deliberately not I actually remember
having the thought like a decade ago
again reminder of how long I've been
working on this freaking thing that the
best adaptation will probably be a TV
show set in the world that maybe crosses
over with some of the events of the book
but is not actually an adaptation
directly of the books
I'm not sure if I still feel that would
be great because that was like my my my
mid late twenties ego you know imagining
all the fame and fortune this book was
gonna bring me oh the folly of youth
what will it take for you to watch years
and years well for starters I'd have to
get a subscription to HBO again so that
would be the first thing cuz I cancelled
it after Game of Thrones ended and no
not out of spite I had always planned to
cancel after Game of Thrones ended would
you like to see any Sarah Jane adventure
will ins appear in Doctor Who I'm not
I'm not sure I would because Sarah Jane
Adventures are pitched so differently
because it is much more that is a kids
show Doctor Who is a family show the
whole family can watch it sir Jane
Adventures really is aimed at kids and
the villains kind of reflect that to a
certain degree I've seen people say that
they want the trickster to come over but
even the trickster is I mean it's the
Saturday morning cartoon version of a
doctor who typed villain I'm not sure
that they would actually cross over very
well to be completely honest about it
let's see hold on ah hold on I had
something then I lost it have you
watched the boys I have not um who would
you say is the worst writer you've seen
or read um I don't know because when I
start reading something that I really
don't enjoy I stop reading it that's the
thing reading something is a much bigger
time commitment than watching a movie or
even you know these days when most shows
don't have more than 13 episodes of
season you know even finishing a season
of a TV show isn't that huge of a time
commitment in the big scale of things
finishing a book that you're not
enjoying that's a slog and I don't do it
have you watched the Umbrella Academy I
did um I I enjoyed it pretty well I
really liked Klaus five
and Hazel especially I didn't love vying
his storyline
I liked it enough that I'm looking
forward to a new season let's see the
problem with changing characters ages is
that it's set at a school
okay so age you won't really get the
chance to change ages then the main
problem with them all being teenagers is
that created a plot hole of where are
ever where are the parents well
depending on the nature of the narrative
and how realistic the setting you're
working in is you can just get away with
that with suspension of disbelief
sometimes because there are certain
genres especially when you're dealing
with school-aged characters certain you
know adventure stories or supernatural
stories or whatever like things like The
Goonies or Buffy the Vampire Slayer or
where you do a slight token
acknowledgement of maybe the parents of
one character but like nobody cares like
it's a logistical plot hole like where
are the parents but if people are here
for what you're doing if they're here
for a teenage adventure story for
example they don't care where the
parents are as long as you're not having
things happen that like would really go
okay that would get back to the parents
and somebody should step in but like if
there just don't seem didn't take a huge
interest in their kids fine just move
forward don't get hung up on things that
are plot holes if the nature of the
genre you're working in actually doesn't
demand that that stuff gets answered
have you seen her star in Joaquin
Phoenix Scarlett Johansson I haven't
spent on my list forever but I have not
what is your favorite time period for a
show or book to be set in um I mean I'm
just fond of completely original world
so then I guess time period removed from
ours you know whether it is far future
altered history fantasy setting you know
basically anything other than the
present anything other than present-day
earth is usually my favorite time and
setting do you have a least favorite
live-action superhero movie um I don't
know maybe maybe Catwoman I don't know
I'd like to write my own take on dr.
Jekyll and mr. Hyde because I believe
Jekel is the real villain he created
hide because he didn't want to take
responsibility for his own actions cool
do it Jacqueline hides in the public
domains you-you-you don't even have to
worry about how much you're ripping off
the original you seen the 1990 Captain
America new I have not Stephen King's on
writing required reading or not for
aspiring writers I haven't read all of
on writing but the little bits and
pieces like snippets I've seen from it
and bits of things that I've seen quoted
from it and general writing advice up a
scene Stephen King give would lead me to
believe probably worth reading again I
haven't but I'm extremely interested in
what kind of music you like oh boy
that's that is a classic drink question
haven't gotten that one in a while I'm
all over the place a lot of soundtrack
stuff a lot of a lot of movie and like
video game soundtracks like a random
smattering of pop and rock like I've got
I've got so many saw like artists that I
have one song from them I don't have a
ton of albums as far as musical artists
or who I have multiple albums for it's
people like Lindsey Stirling pink
miracle sound so some of the big weird
out what is the best horror book or film
you you have ever read I'm not a big fan
of horror movies but I love horror
stories and would love to hear what you
think about it I have a very odd
relationship with horror as a genre
which is that I like a lot of the
trappings of horror but I'm actually not
a big fan of the tropes of horror and
what I mean by that is I love monsters I
love ghosts I love Gothic Atmos
fear but I find most actual horror
stories to be very trophy and very
predictable and adhere very rigidly to
certain formulas and I get bored with
them very quickly that's why I really
love someone like say guillermo del toro
who will take horror tropes and visual
cues and make something like shape of
water or Pan's Labyrinth which are you
know it's arguable how much they are or
aren't horror stories but they're
absolutely steeped in horror iconography
I love that kind of stuff um as far as
the most horrifying movie I ever saw I I
still think the third act kind of lets
it down a bit but um under the skin I
forget what year the movie came out but
it's a Scarlett Johansson movie that
thing is unsettling
as hell well Thank You Kaylee let's see
what we got here in a second what's your
favorite classic short story um it's
funny like short stories have a tendency
to like to a certain degree stick in my
head in terms of like remembering oh I
remember this happened but like then
remembering that name or who wrote it
I'm not great at like one of the only
ones that I can think of I remember
there was a Lovecraft short story that I
read that I cannot remember the name of
now it was written from the perspective
of somebody like trapped in a tomb
trying to get out and I won't say more
of it than that but I remember like
really digging that one again though it
did it not luckily it was like the first
time I'd seen that particular aspect
that ends up happening in that story but
again it's the kind of thing I've ended
up seeing in a lot of other horror
especially horror short stories since
then and that's kind of what I mean
about horror being tropi sorry
scrolling back up
I like horror elements and non horror of
things yeah that's a lot of fun too
explains why you love Buffy it's horri
static but it's a superhero story yeah
pretty much
how many series will you go through
before overdue doctor who reviews finish
well um I am very strongly considering
continuing on through even through stuff
that mysterious color from outer space
it wasn't that one I don't think but I
have read that one that one was
interesting to look I'm not necessarily
gonna recommend Lovecraft it's kind of a
loaded thing to try and get into his
stuff but I found it interesting what
the heck was an answering before that
I'm trying to remember now um I have now
completely lost my train of thought oh
yeah overdue Doctor Who so I may
actually start doing revisit reviews of
stuff I've actually done already done
reviews on so that would be once I hit
day of the doctor
it might go from overdue Doctor Who
review to take to Doctor Who review
we'll see I'm considering it will well
Gus I'm a few years away from that
so we'll see what things are like for me
at that point any main pitfalls to avoid
ruin when writing something for teenage
guys I have no idea cuz I write for
myself that's part of why I'm weird and
iffy on when I tried to answer the
question of who my novel is targeted at
cuz I didn't write it for a specific
target audience I wrote it for me so
that's yeah I'm not even sure if I can
answer that
okay jumping back to the discord real
quick what genre do you enjoy writing
the most um I probably I mean I have the
most fun in fantastical genres so you
know horror sci-fi fantasy just in
general I don't have a specific one of
those three that I enjoy writing the
most but I've messed around in all three
do you write with a purpose in mind at
the beginning and similarly someone on
the discord or
are you the type to plan ahead or right
where the story takes you so I know
where I'm going to end when I sit down
to actually start writing something and
the few occasions where I didn't or I
started writing and I didn't know where
it was gonna finish I never ended up
finishing a story because I I lose a
sense of momentum I need to know a
destination that said I don't thoroughly
outline
I don't do a point for point outline of
the whole thing before I start writing
but I do know ultimately where I'm going
so that I can steer the narrative where
I want it to go
that's not to say that the narrative
can't still surprise me as I go it can
and that has happened especially with
something like the book and other longer
material I it's gone directions and
certain things have happened in certain
characters and certain events in the way
they connected were not planned in
advance and they ended up surprising me
but I do have a destination in mind and
for me personally I kind of need one
because if I don't know where I'm going
eventually I'll lose I'll lose momentum
and I'll lose my drive to finish it so
hold on let me come on back is it okay
to publish fan fiction that's had the
iconic elements altered um I don't know
I
that's really something that I feel like
that's a case-by-case basis thing
because here's what I would say if you
write something that's piece of fan
fiction that is very much deliberately
and explicitly written as fan fiction
and you then want to publish it so you
remove all the copyrightable elements in
my mind ideally you also massage the
narrative or more specifically massage
the characters so they are not just
straight analogs of whoever they started
out with in other words you don't only
change the name but still have the
character effectively function exactly
as the work you
writing fanfiction that said to what
degree you need to do that for it to
late at least in my mind completely
departed from whatever work you
originally derived it from that's kind
of a case-by-case basis thing and I
can't really give you a hard and fast
rule but in my mind you need to do more
than just then just change the names and
what things are called but you have a
bowtie ready for series 5 oh I do indeed
bowtie and fez yes I have both not
related to the topic but what is your
main pet peeves my men my main pet peeve
is people shortening my name because I
mean obviously I have multiple things
that I go by go by Nathaniel I go by
Vera
but I've never gone by Nate or Nathan or
not and I like I don't mind correcting
people once if I have to correct them
more than once I hate that and what I
really hate what drives me nuts almost
more than anything else is it by meeting
somebody for the very first time and I
say hi my name is Nathaniel and they go
hey Nate
nice to meet you if I wanted you to call
me Nate I would have said hi my name's
Nate I didn't said my name's the thing
you like no it's three syllables and
that's a pain in the ass but thanks bot
frickin name you want to talk to me use
it or call me Vera if you want a few
words syllables I'm not gonna say
there's no shortenings of my name that I
accept but it's very limited it's like
because of specific relationship they
have with those people in general I'm
not a not a nickname person that does
drive me absolutely nuts so let me see
how do you feel about people long
anything your name Nick my um I mean if
you if you actually want to write that
out every time I hold on let me see if I
can even
this nathanael it Oh God you see the
things movie on me hold on so this is
this is my long and named Nathaniel and
Dora rung filleth ropa I mean if you
actually want to say it every time I'll
be impressed are you a fan of my
Chemical Romance I actually am NOT I can
never remember if I've actually heard
any other stuff or not like I know the
name enough I've actually heard any of
their songs
Nathaniel Chan oh goodness Nathaniel
ishes oh boy nothing you like Sakura
Fallon Vittorio's oh boy oh this has
become a thing and I kind of love it
alright so I'm gonna jump back to the
discord real quick where do you help
ever every writer even aspiring writers
favorite question where do you get
inspiration from actually more often
than not I've had inspiration spawn off
of like literally either hearing or
thinking one thing and then my brain
starts to build something around that so
like the book that I'm working on now
that I'm doing the working on the final
revision on and hopefully will publish
next year I it spawned completely out of
me
laying in bed in college not being able
to sleep and just having an image in my
head just a very simple image of a young
man laying down and just basically me
just I I was laying down not able to
sleep so I had an image of a young man
laying down not able to sleep and I just
started extrapolating that well why
can't he sleep because he's in pain
is it physical pain no it's um there's
physical sensations but it's something
internal well what is it there's
something inside him that he's trying to
hold back it's endangering other people
he needs to get out and then just
building this this scene around this
initial kernel and as I said that's
actually still in the book that's still
chapter one or the play that I wrote I
almost nobody has read the damn thing
but that entire play which is which has
two characters that has a it has a
female character and a there were pissed
I character it's weird and complicated
and NSFW but there's a there's actually
and it's actually a line in the play
that she says damn well you know I grew
up assuming that nobody would want this
and that was that was something that I
very literate I heard somebody say you
know and I think we were we were hosting
a small gathering and one of the people
there what I thought was a wonderful
beautiful person said that and that
really stuck in my head that this person
who like I thought was stunning thought
that about themselves and just sort of
starting from that kernel I ended up
writing a play just extrapolating from
that so I take inspiration from like
small things that my brain just builds
on and if it builds enough I decide oh I
can do something with that
could you cast to read your play
opposite you if you put it on YouTube
well actually I know exactly who I cast
to read the play and I've actually had
them read it um there's two people in
town here where I live who were not
neither one was the initial inspiration
that I just mentioned a minute ago for
the thing to be written but I always
wrote it with them performing these
characters in mind so like if I had the
disposable income to to be able to fund
a properly recorded
audio drama I would absolutely bring in
the two of them and have them read this
play and release it as an as an audio
and I would love to do that but I can't
I have neither the time nor do I have
the funds nor would I expect to be able
to raise the funds through something
like Kickstarter because like I I
couldn't even get the play to sell very
well so but yeah no I know exactly like
ass and it's nobody you've ever heard of
it's just local actors here in town
where I live oh wow so many hearts oh
that's beautiful
do you like NextWave agents of hate by
Warren Ellis I don't know that one I do
like a lot of Warren Ellis is stuff
though so I'm curious about that
what LEGO sets you have LEGO sets I
don't
I have individual Lego figures which my
partner Liz got me of characters who
have cosplay tasks so I have a poison
ivy and a Wonder Woman and a thirteenth
doctor so hold on I'm gonna I've run a
little over time but that's okay because
I'm having fun cuz II don't going back
to the discord do you have a particular
writing schedule um at the moment I
don't because like I have to grab time
when I can like in an ideal world if if
I ever was able to have my creative
works or my patreon support get me to
the point where I wouldn't have to hold
down a 40-hour a week day job which I
still have I would absolutely have a
writing schedule like three hours in the
morning like first thing that is what I
would like to do that's not what I do
because I can and you know trying to
regularly find writing times is really
hard what I was powering through the
book like that first draft and really
forcing myself to get it done um I was
writing on my lunch break at work at the
time so that was half an hour a day
which is not a lot you can't you
actually don't get all that much done in
a half hour even when you know exactly
what you're doing where you're going but
that was how I powered through getting a
first completed draft art all author's
dead now yes every author is dead it is
true is an audiobook an option down the
road for your fantasy story again if I
can find the means to finance it maybe
like if I had the money personally just
for my own edification I'd want to do an
audio drum of the play before that but I
mean like if by some miracle and I do
not expect this to happen but if by some
miracle if the if the book sells well
yeah sure but like I'm not gonna promise
that or anything what's your opinion of
Slipknot
I have none I just know them as the guys
with the weird mask I don't know a
single piece of music they ever did I
mean I'm sure their stage shows are
amazing I don't doubt that
have you seen Shawshank Redemption my
dad shown to me the other day it's one
of my new favorites I haven't seen that
movie in ages I have seen it it's been
oh it's been a long time though but a
while on that one do you listen to
audiobooks on occasion I've started to
get into the more um but not with any
regularity that's an occasional for me
just started my first theater class at
school and I loved it so much I
I do miss theater classes I miss theater
classes I miss writing classes they were
a lot of fun
who would you say holds more authority
and importance over creative decisions
and a film writer or director of the
director because no matter what a writer
puts down once it's in the directors
hands the writers completely out of the
loop accepting the rare situations where
the writer like is also a producer or
something like that which almost never
happens but you know the minute you put
a script into a directors hands it's not
yours anymore it's theirs now some
directors will reshape a script and mold
it into something else some will just
shoot what they have that depends on the
director but the director is Wayne
more control over the final result than
a writer does and that's not only true a
film that's true of plays I wrote a I
wrote a short play that actually made it
into a festival of ten-minute plays and
I went and saw performed and it
absolutely broke my heart because it's
only a three character play and one of
the actors made choices that I just
hated I absolutely hated what he did
with it but at the same time that's the
nature of theater once it's in the hands
of an actor and a director I can't
control what they do with it it was not
what I wanted it was not what I intended
wasn't what I wanted to see done with
the work but it's what they did I can't
control that that's one of the things
about working in either film or stage
you need to be prepared to relinquish
control cuz you're not gonna have it
have you ever done NaNoWriMo not only
have i done NaNoWriMo quite a few times
i've a actually never completed it
successfully and be almost every year I
tell myself I'm not gonna do it and then
I end up doing it I think the most I
ever did I think the first the furthest
I ever got was like a I got 30,000 words
one year if people don't know NaNoWriMo
National Novel Writing Month which is
November you're the goal is to have
50,000 words new words for a new work
written by the end of the month I've
done it a number of times I've never
completed it successfully and I haven't
finished any of the works that I started
that started as NaNoWriMo things that
said once I get this frigging book
published and off my back I really want
to revisit some of the stuff that
started out as not a Remo projects a lot
of the things you want to do what you
enjoy the most writing burlesque you do
being acting or something else you do um
I can't tell you a favor because
I kind of need all of them I need the
variety in my life what do I like most
whatever what I'm doing at the time I
I need the ability to shift between
different creative modes because either
wise I I stand a Burnout I need to be
able to jump around and so whatever what
I'm doing at the time is generally the
one I really want to be doing right then
uh which keeps me loving it next live
stream topic
Nathaniel gives a live reading of when
she wakes with audience participation Oh
Meg that is cheeky okay so when she
wakes is the name of the play that I
wrote I write I've wrote it I've got it
it's on Amazon under very wild as the
author oh it's you want we should get
tea monetize forever mate yeah that Kerr
woods basically set it right there this
channel will go away for eternity I do
that Bo it would be a fun way to like
commit channel suicide I suppose have
you ever thought about checking out
short trips or be on Big Finish there's
the least expensive and I think they
deserve more love I actually have um and
also Big Finish has like a sort of a
contest thing that they do every year
that I wanted to to pitch something for
this year but I couldn't get anything
pulled together in time I'm gonna keep
an eye out for it next year
you should definitely check out a Thai
kawauti keys TED talk it talks a lot
about being a creative person yet
channelling back through a variety of
different mediums cool I greatly enjoy
watching your videos and these live
chats please don't ever stop don't plan
to I love doing this and like it is my
hope to try and continue to grow the
channel in the patreon so that this can
be how I make my living
I'm still a long way off from that and
the but the the level I've already
gotten to is amazing and higher than I
ever thought I would so I still have
hope but you know it's a long way off
did you finally see the video that LGBTQ
YouTube made about the legal action they
were taking against YouTube I did um I
had a hard time finding much write-ups
about it in terms of the specifics of
the lawsuit which is kind of what I'm
curious about I saw the video like
announcing that they were doing it and
I'm curious but like I really want to
find out a lot more of the specifics of
exactly what they're claiming and
exactly what recompense they're seeking
because depending on the angle they're
coming at this from I could
theoretically get behind it but this is
the kind of thing that you need to
present a very careful legal case for
because uh otherwise you're just you're
just making a show and I honestly am not
sure how much that helps especially
given that it doesn't actually seem to
be giving that much press so I really
hope that it's being presented on very
sound legal footing because it doesn't
seem to be making much of a splash
otherwise so a favorite series of Doctor
Who series for wait yeah what's going on
with LGBTQ YouTube yeah see that's kind
of my point
um so make what's happened is this there
are a number of LGBTQ plus YouTube
creators none of whom were people I knew
but they're but they're all bigger than
me who have rallied together and are
suing Google and YouTube for
discrimination I mean at least as I
understand it and again I can't find a
lot of details on the case they have
actually brought and whether or not suit
has actually been filed or if they've
just said they're going to but you know
running experiments like uploading the
exact same video but having one of the
it was uploaded say LGBTQ and the like
in the description and that got to
monetized and the one that didn't have
that didn't get to monetize even though
it was the exact same video and they're
using things like that to build a case
an anti-discrimination case um again I
don't know enough about it to know how
sound the legal footing is that's what
I'm really curious about because I hope
it's solid because if it's not then this
is a this is an attempt to bring a
public eye to a problem that is failing
because the public doesn't seem to know
about this I didn't know about this
until I got asked about it in the chat
so I really hope it has solid legal
ground because if if their only hope was
to make a big splash and start a
conversation it hasn't done that which I
was able to support financially
unfortunately not able to at this time
in life when I can I definitely will
become a patron you deserve it for the
joy you bring well thank you Brittany
and yeah like I I know I mentioned the
patreon and like it's amazing the level
of support I get and when I get you know
this I got the super chat on this and
anytime somebody drops something in
there that's amazing but I I don't I I
really kind of want to be careful I
don't ever want people to feel like I'm
trying to guilt-trip them but you know
it would be really nice to to have to
have this be how I how I pay my bills
didn't you have that happen with your
hashtags um not on this channel on the
very wild channel I went through several
months of everything getting demonetized
the instant it went up and then always
getting cleared on review and then it
happened here at the same time and my
suspicion was I'm not as solid in this
at the time that I said it but my
suspicion was they had facial
recognition clocked me as being the same
person as running the mirror wall
channel and they were automatically
flagging those uploads so they started
automatically fighting council of geeks
and they both stopped at around the same
time so I have a suspect
in that that was a case where doing
daily uploads actually really helped me
because I think that after who knows how
many but enough times of they do
monetize I I asked for a review I clear
the review de monetize review clear de
monetize review clear I think after
doing that I don't know 100 times in a
row
they stopped Auto flagging me but that's
supposition on my part I don't know cuz
YouTube and Google doesn't talk to
anybody
one of my close to friends recently came
out to me as transgender and is
terrified about coming out to her
parents any advice for a friend wanting
to be there for them ask if they want an
ally in the room when they come out
don't inject yourself there but ask if
they would like you there because having
somebody there that they know has their
back can be a really big help be a
really big boost this is for everyone
who can't donate oh thank you silent
chariot I prefer classic to new whoo but
I think classic who's pacing is
overrated for parters are like but some
stories you can tell them 45 minutes
sorry should be as long as they need to
be I'll agree with you on that Ben every
now and then I'll come across a classic
story that's you know I'll come across
six partners that could have been five
four partners that could have been three
most four partners are okay but I find
that in most things that are more than
four parts long there's usually at least
one episode that feels like filler hold
on I'm gonna jump on back to the discord
to see if there are any that I missed
over there do you have any advice on how
to get started as a freelance writer
I really don't cuz I don't consider
myself to be a freelance writer is one
of those things that like if I didn't
have a 40-hour a week job I would be
putting myself out more for you know
pitching articles to websites or
publications and trying to build a
freelance portfolio but I just I don't
have time with the YouTube
and full-time job and trying to do that
is the kind of thing that I could do if
I either wasn't doing as much YouTube as
I do or wasn't doing the 40-hour work
week but since I need the 40-hour work
week and I really enjoy the YouTube and
actually at this point it does pay
enough to basically be a second job for
me and then I really I don't have the
time and the energy to to push my
something to try and get enough
freelance work what I would say though
in general is if you know the kinds of
things that you feel you have
qualifications or solid pitches to write
about just start just start looking at
online you have notable online news
sites or article sites that write about
that kind of thing and most of them will
have a submission page where you can
pitch them an idea so just start
pitching and maybe it'll get picked up
and then ideally you'll build a
portfolio freelance work and then maybe
they'll even start coming to you if you
do that for long enough but again that's
Meis kind of how I think it's supposed
to go I haven't actually succeeded at
that and I haven't even really properly
tried again cuz I don't have the time
let's see I think if we got one more
here
so I do a similar thing for my stories
that you that you said you do an image
comes to mind or a character and it just
builds and builds how do you stop it
from building like not to expand too
much to stay focus on what's at hand I
mean that's a big part of why I need to
know where I'm going and I need to know
where I'm choosing to end the story
because otherwise things balloon and get
out of control if I know where I'm
ending then I know at what point I can
stop building a character or world
because at a certain point I'm building
stuff that doesn't feed into or affect
the narrative and then I know I can say
we stop I think I am gonna wrap it up
soon really starting to hate your job no
comment but
that's the end of my water if you were
writing fantasy for children what would
you do different I actually did start
for one of the NaNoWriMo started things
that I started I did start a fantasy
book that was aimed at a younger
audience than the book I'm mostly
talking about today and that you know I
knew was gonna have a slightly more
whimsical feel I knew it was probably
gonna be shorter it has a younger
protagonist so things like that again I
didn't finish it so I have a concept but
part of the reason I didn't finish that
one is I didn't know how it was gonna
end I had a concept and a pitch and a
character and a set up but I didn't know
how to end it and I was part of how why
I lost steam on that one so that's kind
of what I said before last drops of
water gone yes indeed did you hear about
the Smosh member Courtney who recently
came out as lesbians great see lgbtq+
members anywhere I don't really follow
Smosh or their stuff but I mean like
anyone who is able to come out and not
have it completely destroy their lives
that's awesome and amazing and if you
come out of it does destroy your life
you know I that's terrible for you but I
still you know wish those people the
best as well but yeah I think I'm gonna
wrap it up
so reminder slip one more pitch in there
I have started a writer diary an
author's diary for this book that I'm
all waiting to not not hoping I will
publish in some form by the by next by
the end of next year and if you are
interested in that it is a patreon
exclusive any level of support will get
you access to those videos the first one
went up today it'll that'll be bi-weekly
and as I start ramping up to the actual
release of the book I may know I will
release like highlights and pare down
version of of the author diary on here
probably as like as a to build of
marketing steam but for the the more
complete thing that'll be that'll be on
patreon link in the description hey
there it is
alright so I hope everybody has a good
night have a good rest of the week happy
writing
and just remember folks that you are
beautiful you are loved you are valid
and you are the counsel
I'm just running the meetings and
apparently writing a book in my spare
time
what spare time I don't know must have
some I wrote the dang thing have a good
night everybody